Hi, my name is Baba Shiv.
I'm a professor of marketing at
the Graduate School of Business.
[MUSIC]
>> When it comes to our
communication, many of us make
a fundamental mistake.
We start from the wrong place.
We start by saying,
this is what I want to say,
rather than thinking about what our
audience needs to hear.
>> As it turns out,
most of our stakeholders are drawn
to examples, that is why people buy
lottery tickets.
Even though the actual probability
of winning
the lottery is extremely low.
>> There's a famous saying here
in Silicon Valley that if
you're a startup founder
going to an investor for
money, you're going to get advice.
You go for advice,
you're going to get money.
So what do you do is that
go to the stakeholder you're
trying to influence, you're trying
to get a buy in from and
what you do is seek advice.
The person will provide advice.
Now the person's brain has gotten
invested in your idea.
Now your idea will become
that person's baby as well.
[MUSIC]
>> As a leader with
a coherent strategy,
you have a method to your madness.
Your strategy is your unique way of
connecting the dots.
Whenever you ask someone to
accomplish a specific objective,
always help them see how it fits
into the bigger story.
>> When it comes to making
decisions about other people, those
can be immensely consequential.
They can relate to
their livelihood,
to their sense of worth,
to their psychological well-being.
We can't take those lightly.
[MUSIC]
>> Here are a few things
we tell our students
about how to de risk your humor.
First, don't ask,
will this make me sound funny?
Instead, asked how will this make
other people feel?
Which also means never punching
down, that is making fun of someone
of lower status.
And be sure to check your distance.
How close are you personally to
what you're making light of.
I can make fun of my mother,
but not Jennifer's mother,
who by the way I hear is a saint.
>> She is a saint, thank you.
>> A lovely woman.
[MUSIC]
>> My mum once sat in a class and
at the end of the class she said to
me, Amir, I have no idea what you
said, but you're a genius.
>> Start taking humor seriously.
>> Seriously.
>> Seriously, [LAUGH] >> I'm not,
and I disagree on everything.
>> No, Rob you're wrong,
we don't disagree on everything,
we agree on many things, actually.
>> Okay, eventually yes,
we do end up agreeing
on everything.
[MUSIC]